welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Tom Davidson Tom is a senior
research analyst at open philanthropy
where he works with potential risks from
Advanced AI Tom welcome to the podcast I
guess it's a pleasure to be here so
we're going to spend a lot of time on
your model of takeoff speeds where you
come to some pretty wild conclusions in
in my opinion but first I think would be
great to to kind of situate your your
model in your broader views so maybe you
could tell us a bit about your view of
AI progress and AI risks in in general
in Broad terms so in Broad terms I think
AI progress in the last 10 years has
been extremely rapid
there's been massive progress in terms
of analyzing images and videos
in terms of creating images and videos
game playing natural language ability
coding kind of very kind of diverse
broad domains seeing very rapid progress
and all within a very similar Paradigm
the Deep learning Paradigm where
progress has been fueled by training
larger neural Nets with with more
compute and by kind of improving the
neural net algorithms the Deep learning
algorithms we're using to train those
things
and I think progress in the last four
years has been especially rapid so four
years ago gpt2 was released if you
haven't played Ram with gpd2 I really
recommend you do so it's a brilliant way
to kind of give you yourself an
intuition fund for just how fast this
this field has been moving gpt2 is you
know by today's standards a very limited
language conversational chat bot AI
um it can maybe string together a few
sentences but once once it's written a
paragraph it's very clear it doesn't
know what it's talking about it's off
topic it can't really understand
questions you ask it it's clearly very
very
um limited as as an AI and has a very
limited brittle understanding of the
world
that was four years ago this year gpt4
was released gp4 was probably actually
trained in 2022
um so you know arguably three or four
years being the gap between gpt2 and dp4
and again if you haven't you know played
around with gvd4 then I strongly
recommend you do so you'll need to pay
some kind of subscription fee on the
open AI chat DBT interface or there's
other other ways you can play around
with it but you know in my opinion if
you're asking it you know probing
questions and really testing its
knowledge it's quite a lot stronger than
Chad GPT 3.5 and my goodness compared to
gbt2 it is it is really very good you
know it has seems to have a pretty
strong pretty General understanding of
many aspects of the world you know it
will apply its knowledge pretty flexibly
if you try and throw kind of curveballs
at it it's it's very good at coding
um it can you know you can give it a
natural language description of some
code you want it to write it'll write
the code you can ask it to make certain
tweaks it'll make just exactly those
tweaks I don't see why I need to kind of
I sometimes do like little python kind
of coding experiments for work and I I
would be math you know have a much
better job having done those projects
Now using using dpt4 you know in the
last four years we've gone from g52 to
gp4 I I think that's just very startling
and so yeah progress has been rapid and
it's you know been getting faster I
think
and I think that absent like kind of
people deciding to be cautious and
decided deciding to go slower to a kind
of non-financial non-commercial reasons
I think the next four years will
probably be similarly quick and that
will see a continued fast scaling up of
the Transformer architecture that is
behind the DBT models and I expect that
by default that kind of same jump that
we saw from gfd2 to dvd4 will get a
similar size jump
in the next four years maybe it'll take
slightly longer because scaling does
become more expensive as as you start to
you know really be spending you know
more than a billion on on these training
runs this is the progress and as I
understand we're just saying it AI is
moving incredibly quickly what about the
risks how do you see the risk landscape
resulting from this quick progress so
there are already risks that AI is
posing there's risks of
disinformation there's risks of
embedding biases
um in society that that are kind of
inherent in the data that the natural
language models are trained on and as AI
gets more capable I expect the kind of
severity
um of those risks to increase and align
with this capabilities you know it's
very hard to speak definitively about
exactly what risk will arise when
because one of the things about language
models is that it's it's hard to predict
what emergent capabilities there will be
with the next model so you know these
models are pre-trained by kind of just
devouring Tech you know internet text
just basically reading all of the um
text that people can easily scrape off
the internet and trying to predict what
the next word will be on a given web
page
um that they're presented with and then
it turns out that you know that
pre-training
um just kind of reading things on the
internet gives the language models
various kind of emerging capabilities
um which are not in any you know very
obvious Direction present in the
training set
um but I kind of can be can be kind of
elicited
um from the models with a little bit of
tweaking
um after that initial phase is finished
so you know for example I believe that
some people are concerned that the next
generation of large language models that
might be G55 might make it significantly
easier for Bad actors to create
um dangerous bioweapons and presumably
that's because there's enough kind of
biology related text on the internet
that when it's doing that pre-training
phase gp5 would be picking up enough on
biology and also just enough kind of
Common Sense reasoning and scientific
understanding in general that it could
then provide substantial help to someone
who's wanting to make a bio weapon of
that kind but it's very hard to predict
whether that will actually happen it's
it's hard to know exactly what is in the
training data and exactly what the
language models will be able to get out
of that training data when the whole
thing is is over and done with but you
know I think that that that that is one
particular risk that I think there's
there's there's a decent chance of
arising in the next four years
this kind of lowering the bar to
bioterrorism risk
um I think there's some chance
um of a risk that has been has been
called I'm kind of autonomous
replication and adaption
that is that some maybe G55 level
systems or dp6 level systems would be
capable with the right kind of
scaffolding to help them along
um either something like
um Auto GPT that kind of prompts the um
system to kind of kind of plan out its
actions and make a list of sub goals and
then pursue them one by one I think
there's a chance that a system of that
kind would be capable of kind of copying
itself onto a onto a new computer
um and then using
um that computers compute resources to
make money for example by scamming
people or by just kind of doing
um intellectual work on the internet
that humans can get paid for
um like doing kind of M Turkish style
roles and so there's a chance we make
this threshold where AI is kind of able
to self-sustain
um and kind of gather at their own the
resources it needs to kind of kind of
make more copies of itself and increase
its its power and resources and these
two risks you mentioned are very near
terms so we're thinking here before 2027
or
before 2028 yeah I think there's a
chance for sure like I said it's really
hard to predict and especially with this
um autonomous replication and an
adaption threshold you know my own view
is probably more likely than not that
that is not possible by 2027 2028 but I
I'd give it substantial probability you
know more you know maybe 30 percent
um and then probably higher on the on
the buyer risk whether I'm really kind
of making these numbers up these are
just my very loose Impressions and
um I don't know I'm not aware of a very
grounded science for
um predicting these kind of risks
and you know there are there are other
risks as well these not the only ones
maybe there's risks from persuasion
um propaganda maybe recruitment for Bad
actors they can use
um language models to automate the
process of kind of reaching out and
trying to find vulnerable people maybe
they're maybe there are other risk as
well we'll see in the next five years
maybe relating to cyber maybe relating
to um significantly improving Tech
progress and in some domain yeah and I
think what you mentioned is that that
you can't really predict which
capabilities will arise and I think one
of the problems here is that nobody can
really predict which capabilities will
arise and this makes the whole area very
uncertain if you couple that with the
fact that as you mentioned the area is
moving very fast you get some some
potential risks going on yeah exactly
and I think one thing that can make it
harder to manage these risks is that the
default way that we regulate risky
technology is a kind of reactive way so
we allow people to develop the
technology we kind of allow them to
deploy it and then when something goes
wrong we say okay that thing went wrong
in that particular circumstance we're
going to regulate the use of this
technology in this circumstance so now
now you're not allowed to use AI to do
political campaigns because we've seen
it's been abused in that context
and what I think we probably need for
something like AI when there's so many
possible risks and it's really hard to
predict which ones there's something a
bit more proactive where we are
um before deploying it far and wide
testing it in advance what kind of risks
it it may pose does this mean that we
don't really have any good historical
analogies for AI with other Technologies
it may be the case that it's taken
decades for them to be deployed and
we've been able to do trial and error
and build up some sort of safety regime
but maybe AI is different maybe it moves
much faster than other Technologies do
you have good analogies in mind I don't
think there are any perfect amount IDs
to be sure I think your pointer I think
a good a good tension which makes it
hard to find analogies and the AI is a
general purpose technology so in that
sense it's like harnessing power from
fossil fuels or electricity or maybe
computing power but on the other hand
unlike other general purpose
Technologies the under the underlying
technology is is improving very very
rapidly so with fossil fuels
you know that I'm not aware of any kind
of four-year period where we saw this
kind of rate of improvement in the
underlying kind of quality of the
combustion engine and I'm not aware of
you know similarly with with something
like electricity any any four-year
period where there was such rapid
progress in that underlying technology
and I think you know that there have
probably been you know many many narrow
Technologies like you know Facebook but
you know when filing a number of small
number of years but it's it's a narrow
domain and that did in fact pose
regulatory problems you know the
government was was either be too slow to
respond to the various risks that
Facebook did did pose
um but you know ultimately it was a very
scoped narrow technology in a narrow
domain with AI I think there's a kind of
a scary Duality with its with its
generality on the one hand and then the
kind of underlying poster progress on
the other hand making it especially
difficult to imagine regulate as a new
technology yeah and if we look longer
terms so beyond the 2030s what do you
think of the possibility of truly
transformative AI when would you expect
something like that to arrive what is a
good way of defining whether AI is
transformative
so one kind of broad news definition
which has been used historically is to
say that AI be transformative if it
changed society as much as the
Industrial Revolution change society or
the Agricultural Revolution change
society okay what I understand by that
is it's completely changing the nature
of work going from 100 Gathering to
farming and you know kind of moving
around constantly to being settled in
one place then moving into industry and
it's also completely changing the way
that Society is structured and the
political and economic processes that
are appropriate that's not very precise
to definition but it is has the benefit
of of being kind of kind of loose and
flexible enough that if you're kind of
trying to interpret it in the right way
then it's probably going to end up
pointing at the thing that you care
about I think that's a pretty robust
definition to use because it's vague
people have tried to kind of precisify
the definition and then I think that
there are some problems you you run into
when you do that so one way to try and
make it precise is to say hey it's truly
transformative if it accelerates the
pain case of economic growth by say a
factor of 10. that's more precise but it
does have the downside that whether
economic growth gets fast it doesn't
just depend on the nature of AI itself
it also depends on how it's integrated
into society and how humans choose to
use it like we might just choose to grow
slowly despite the possibility of
growing much faster you know because it
depends on how do we even measure
economic growth there's this big kind of
thorny questions about how you measure
the growth impact of new technologies
and at that point the thing that your
the definition of transformative AI is
so tied to its impact rather than to the
actual abilities of the technology
itself that I think it can be confusing
to think about it like that
an approach I often use is to use the
term artificial general intelligence and
just say that that is when AI can do any
cognitive task that a human professional
can do
um at at or above that level that's
precise
um fairly precise and I prefer it to to
the kind of Economics based definition
because it's more about what the
underlying technology can do
on the other hand you can imagine kind
of loopholes where it's not really
capturing what you want where there's
like just a few tasks that no one's
bothered trying to make AI able to do
that
um that AI can't do so you say oh we
don't technically for AGI and so I think
probably sticking with the kind of broad
definition is is used to want to have in
the background and then being a bit
flexible about exactly how
um we're defining it thinking about the
economic impact of AI is interesting
because sometimes if you look at
benchmarks for example gpt4 scores very
well on high school exams and and call
its exams and even the bar exam and so
on but how does that translate into
economic growth or economic progress or
automation it's difficult to say and and
of course the gbt4 hasn't there hasn't
been enough time yet for it to have a
great impact but so far it's not really
showing up in the numbers I think it's
very important to think of the economic
impact also and not just the benchmarks
yeah I I think especially today is
benchmarks are very limited so what if
AI can get you know this Mark on an SAT
and so what if it can get get this go on
big bent
the task that we're mostly focusing on
with current benchmarks are not tasks
that humans are performing in the real
world in the real economy that they're
actually useful to producing goods and
services to you know running
organizations to whatever it is that
people are actually trying to do with
the current way we're benchmarking
systems that there's this kind of gap
between the tests that we're giving them
and then the stuff that we actually
ultimately care about in our society
which is kind of useful work and it's
really hard to know how big that Gap is
and it seems like at the moment that Gap
is potentially pretty big
and that gpd4 is getting really good
grades on a very wide range of quite
tough examinations but it's not yet
massively adopted to replace lots of
people's jobs and to massively improve
increase profits and revenues for lots
of companies and so I think we should be
trying to move towards data benchmarks
which are more closely tied to
um the actual real world impacts of the
systems yeah and maybe those benchmarks
will be difficult to set up but at least
we have measurements of GDP growth as a
proxy for useful work as one way of
measuring whether AI is is doing a lot
of useful work for the economy yeah
that's right it's really getting it back
is it doing useful work part of the
question I do think it has some pretty
big downsides in that there's going to
be a pretty big lag especially with
earlier AI systems that they're less
flexible and so take more work to
integrate into workflows so if you're
just looking at you know GDP you might
think nothing really that much is
happening in in AI because you know GDP
hasn't picked up and that would be a
mistake and there's also just a lot of
noise and in GDP statistics just
inherent noise and then you know all
these other Trends which are interlacing
and what one kind of quite nice
intermediate is the size of the AI the
AI industry specifically so you can look
at investments in AI or you can try and
kind of add up AI driven revenues across
the economy which I think is a pretty
vexed task trying to you know figure out
how much value-ad AI is really adding
those kinds of measurements typically
show pretty fast growth the AI industry
kind of like 30 a year or faster in
recent history you can also look at
things like growth of spending on AI
chips that's quite a kind of concrete
thing you can measure clearly that is
maybe intermediate between economic
growth and the one hand and benchmarks
on the other hand that it is showing
look people really believe that this is
going to have a real world impact
they're willing to spend you know
concrete money
um developing these systems that means
you're getting a kind of real signal
about Its Real World impact but you know
it hasn't actually had that impact yet
so that's that's intermediate it's also
interesting to think about the fact that
the entire introduction of computers and
the internet to the world over the last
50 years hasn't really increased the
growth rate in developed economies a lot
so Technologies can have a an enormous
real world impact without actually
increasing GDP and maybe there's a quite
a high bar actually for what we might
call transformative AI yeah I think
there's a very high bar as you say
computers
you know they did increase economic
growth in the sense that if we hand
developed computers economic growth
would have been lower but they did not
turbocharge the overall pace of economic
growth they're more kind of maintaining
the trend that we were previously
getting from other Technologies and you
know at first I think that that's what
will be happening with AI and then you
know my view is that once we've got you
know truly very Advanced systems you
know AGI systems that are able to you
know really automate all all human labor
that's that's when we should expect
um more transformative and like
unprecedented economic impacts yeah and
what I want to do in this episode is to
kind of dig into your model of how this
might happen uh which is I think
centered around the takeoff speeds I
think the notion of takeoff speeds is
quite Central to how you see AI
progressing so maybe we could start by
talking about what what is takeoff speed
in the context of of AI so I think it
can be useful to distinguish between two
Notions of takeoff speed
the first is what I'll call AI
capabilities take of speed so that's
that's focused on the on Pace of
improvement and the underlying
technology
so capabilities take up speed would be
the answer to the question of how
quickly is AI improving around the time
in which we get human level AI
so if if take up speed is fast then that
can mean we go from kind of mouse level
intelligence AI to human level AI in one
year and then a year later we've got
kind of Godlike intelligence AI so kind
of very fast increase in AI capabilities
just as passing through the kind of
human level of intelligence then there's
another notion of takeoff speed which I
think especially if we're thinking about
economic impacts it can be
um useful to distinguish which is impact
take of speed so that is how quickly
does ai's impact in the world increase
around that time a very fast impact tape
of speed could look like growth is just
ticking away and it's normal two or
three percent a year and then next year
suddenly it kind of shoots up a lot of
economy is is doubling every every two
years
with explosive growth whereas a more
kind of slow impact type of speed could
be well there's the impacts of AI is
spread out over
um many decades and you know maybe
growth gradually gets faster over time
or maybe it only temporarily gets faster
than it set us back down and so you know
you could you could imagine those two
coming apart if there's sort of loads of
regulations for example that limit the
impact of AI you can imagine that the
under the takeoff speed of the
underlying technology being very fast
kind of somewhat in line with recent
recent Trends but the actual impact take
us B being much slower so a lot of
probably we'll talk later about some of
the economic objections to to kind of
transformative growth and various
bottlenecks I know one one kind of theme
in my mind is that these things tend to
affect impact take of speed more than
they tend to affect the capabilities
take up speed so what do you think a
world looks like in which you have
a lot of AI capabilities but not a lot
of impact yet is that a stable situation
because it seems to me pretty unstable
there would be a lot of incentives to
try to deploy these very capable AI
somewhere in the world yeah I think
that's right it's probably temporary the
reason you can imagine it happening is
that there are lots of entrenched
interests in in various professions so
no lawyers don't want to lose their jobs
medical professionals don't want to lose
their jobs there are unions there's kind
of political processes by which these
groups kind of willpower and influence
and they may want to delay the
deployment of systems which would
replace them and use their jobs and
indeed that will be a very good thing
um there's regulations around who can
make various high-stage decisions be it
in signing something on the legal
document or giving a drug to a patient
your options take a while to shake up
and it's not going to happen overnight
that suddenly AIS are allowed to you
know give you diagnose you and hand you
the medication even if they're actually
able to do that and because these are
slow human processes and bureaucracies
it does seem possible to me that even
though there's a large amount of
pressure to kind of remove these
barriers to Rolling Out AI that it could
still take a while so what you're
imagining here is for example we have
AI models capable of diagnosing a
patient or sending a document to a court
because of a professional organization
in medicine or in law maybe it's just
not legal to do so maybe you need a
human to sign off or maybe you need even
a human to to do the full task and that
slows down the implementation of of AI
in the economy even though AIS might be
perfectly capable of diagnosing a
patient yeah even though they might be
better do you think that's the default
scenario has this happened before I
think that is the default in our
previous Technologies
they do take a while to refuse and if
you kind of had a naive view of like
well once it's better then everyone will
move over you'd be you'd be very
surprised at what ended up happening in
reality
you know many
organizations have still not
transitioned over
to the internet fully I sometimes go
into
um I've gone into hospitals and I'm
asked to fill out forms by hand and I'm
thinking why why are we still doing
paper documents here these transitions
can be sewn I I don't I actually think
there's a chance that things are quite
different with AI so if the capabilities
take up speed is fast then we might
rapidly transition to a world where
we've got you know truly super
intelligent systems that are not yet
deployed that could very damage to be
add huge amounts of value at kind of
almost no effort to integrate them into
our businesses could add huge amounts of
value because they're kind of smart
enough to incubate themselves and
immediately kind of like learn what they
need to learn prior activity and start
having value
at that point I think the situation will
be without precedent and that we've
never the previous technologies have
required active effort to rearrange
workflows you know kind of draft new
legislation so that they can be
incorporated
um into the real economy
it would be without precedent for a new
technology to be able to do all of that
work itself
drop the new legislation itself Lobby
The Regulators itself roll you know
learn what it needs to learn to do an
even better job delivering um the goods
and services itself create by itself you
know legible examples of inventing and
treating diseases which people currently
struggle to treat and maybe AI systems
are so super intelligent that they can
without even going through the FDA
process develop a new drug and then kind
of demonstrate quite clearly to everyone
that it works in in treating cancer that
no one else can treat then at that point
you know legally new jobs need to go
through the FDA but when there's
something so Stark has there's this drug
which could save millions of lives
everyone knows it would work that would
create a kind of pressure on the system
and the regulatory system the change
that I think might be without Preston
and so I could I could imagine that if
if AI capabilities continue to kind of
shoot upwards that would put increasing
pressure on the kind of the regulatory
barriers and other barriers to deploying
AI widely it's of course difficult to
speculate on the political economy of
future AI but I think that there might
also be demand from the public to to get
access to these AI models if for example
you have a demonstration that that an AI
doctor can diagnose you better than a
human doctor
and maybe the AI doctor costs
10 times as as little of course there
would be pressure coming from from the
doctors Association in in a given
country but I can't see this demand not
mattering at all I think it will matter
uh at least somewhat I think that's
right in my mind it's question of how
long and then there's kind of the kind
of incumbent forces trying to preserve
the status quo and then there's this
maybe increasing tide of kind of
technological abilities the AI is able
to provide quite an increasing pressure
to kind of knock down those barriers and
then also kind of competitive Dynamics
potentially you have two different
states have slightly different
regulations and people all go to the to
the state where they can get the kind of
10 times cheaper AI Doctor Who's more
effective or they'll go to a different
country where they can receive that
treatment and that's that's another
thing which which makes it hard for
these incoming forces to you know
sustain for for too long yeah I think
before we get into the mechanics of the
model itself I I it would be useful to
know why you're interested in this topic
why is it useful for us to know about AI
takeoff speeds one of the key risks that
I've been focused on with AI is is the
risk of losing control
of superhuman AI systems that is systems
which on
some significant domains maybe
persuasion maybe strategy maybe
technological development
out to perform best human experts these
risks are very poorly understood we
don't yet have a solution to what people
refer to as the alignment problem which
is a problem of ensuring that superhuman
AI systems do what debt users intend and
their developers intent what this means
is that it would be really really useful
if we could have you know a long period
of time like ideally Decades of time
with
AI systems which are not quite yet
capable enough to actually pose a risk
that we lose control of them but that
are kind of maybe almost at that level
or that are very similar to those
particularly risky systems in in key
ways so that we could study them we
could understand how how do their
motivation systems work we could
experiment with different ways to try
and align them I kind of trained them
such that they do
um what their users and developers want
them to do and we could we could learn
about how big the risks are and the best
ways of mitigating those risks and so
that would be really really nice in
terms of better understanding the
problem and understanding you know what
the solution requires the problem is
that if capabilities take off speed is
fast I if the underlying technology goes
from Human level to kind of
significantly superhuman in just a year
then we won't have very long or we Yeah
by default we won't have very long with
those systems we won't have longer study
about I think that makes the task of
avoiding loss of control
much more difficult because if we just
have one year then we'll be kind of
flying by the seat of our pants trying
to kind of understand how these systems
work how they think
throwing on some kind of very quick slap
Dash Solutions in terms of trying to get
them to do what we want and then not
really having time to take a step back
and check that it's all working in just
one year very little effort so far has
gone into solving this this problem of
how do we retain control of superhuman
systems
if we had a very long time with AIS
you're a roughly human level maybe a
very slightly superhuman the kind of
research but kind of let maybe human
level or less than human level are the
kind of dangerous capabilities like
manipulation and persuasion and
strategizing we had if we had many
decades with with systems of that kind
we could potentially use them to try and
solve the problem of understanding
um the motivations of AI systems and and
solving this problem of how do we
control superhuman AI systems once you
train a system that's human level I
think it's likely you'll be able to run
and we can talk about this a bit later
but you'll be able to run many millions
of copies in parallel all the same time
or even run kind of fewer copies but
have them think
um faster and so you could get a huge
amount of Labor from kind of Highly
capable Ai and the best time to do that
is when again when you've got AI that is
you're really pretty good and good
enough to be very useful but not yet
kind of superhuman enough that it's
really posing a risk that you lose
control over and so again if we had a
slow takeoff we could have many years
harnessing the labor of these roughly
human level AI systems and and why is it
that in a fast takeoff scenario we can't
harness their labor to help us align
more advanced AI why why is it more
difficult to do so in a fast takeoff
scenario so in a fast takeoff we can
still do this to some extent
there will still be some period where we
have roughly human level systems and we
can use them to do research into keeping
AIS safe
but we just have less Long and that
period and so they they can do less
research in total and especially if we
want humans to be able to check the
results of their work and we want humans
to be able to verify their work then
that kind of only having 12 months could
become quite a binding constraint
you know even if we don't need humans to
check there's still this batch of you
just got longer to do the research that
desire that I think we all have for
humans to verify the work and could
become quite
but quite problematic all right so if we
begin digging into your model I'm
looking at a simplified diagram of it
there there's also a website where you
can plug in your own values for various
parameters so maybe we could we could go
through the parameters of the model and
talk about the relationships yeah how
would you summarize the model
it attempts to
model the most important
inputs to AI development
in particular the amount of compute used
to develop an AI model
and the quality of the algorithms
um the training algorithms that are you
that that kind of utilize that compute
to produce the trained AI
and then it really kind of drills into
okay
how are these two inputs currently
evolving over time and how might they
evolve over time into the future so you
know how quickly all the algorithms be
improving into the future
um how how quickly will the amount of
compute use to develop AI systems
increase into the future and in
particular taking into account a couple
of key feedback loops
um so the first feedback loop is a kind
of an investment feedback loop where we
we see the AIS are producing value in
the economy and we see from impressive
demos that they're very capable and that
Sparks increased Financial investment
kind of getting more compute and
improving algorithms and then a second
feedback loop which are called the AI
automation feedback loop whereby as AIS
get more capable they're able to
automate the work of coming up with
better AI algorithms and they're able to
automate the work of coming up
um with with a better computer chip so
that we have access to more compute and
so we've got these these two feedback
loops investment feedback loop in the AI
automation feedback loop they are both
affecting how the algorithms are
improving and how the amount of compute
available is improving and then those
two key inputs are then driving the
Improvement of air capabilities over
time and so which of these feedback
loops is the most important so is the is
the investment feedback loop or the AI
automation feedback loop the most
important for accelerating takeoff
speeds I think in the near term the
investment feedback loop is going to be
more important so I think already today
we're seeing that feedback loop in
action investment in AI has gone up
massively in recent years investment in
AI chip I've gone up massively
investment in designing better AI chips
have gone up massively
um Nvidia
um it's share price has gone through the
roof you know it specializes in AI chips
like the h100 and So currently it's that
investment feedback loop which is
continuing to drive the very fast
program that we've seen over the last
four years and we'll probably continue
to see over the next four years
but that investment feedback loop can
only continue for so long because at a
certain point
companies are already spending maybe
hundreds of billions of dollars maybe
even a trillion dollars if it becomes a
nation state activity
on developing a state-of-the-art AI
system
and it's just very hard to spend more
um past a certain point and you know
past a certain point you'd have to
expand the whole semiconductor industry
so you can actually you know increase
the number of cheetah chips produced
worldwide in order to continue to grow
that investment
um at the pace which has been growing
recently and so over time I expect the
investment feedback lead to become less
important and the
AI automation feedback loop become more
important
um in particular once AI gets the point
where it's able to automate significant
fractions of the work done by AI
researchers to improve AI by
um dip design companies like Nvidia to
design better AI chips by um fabrication
companies like tsmc who who actually
manufacture Cutting Edge chips as AI
automate their the kind of works that
those organizations do
um this this feedback loop will come
into play and then as I gets more and
more capable the feedback loops will
become more and more significant over
time yeah as I understand it you've been
working on this model for three or four
years at least you've been working on
this model before the release of chat
GPT which I think accelerated AI
investment do you have any any sense of
how much AI Investments have increased
since grgbt investment in U.S
semiconductors has been kind of growing
an unprecedented rate
probably in part related to the chips
act whereby the US government is
spending money to try and encourage
um these bad companies like tsmc to move
their Fabs to the US you know hearing
about lots of new startups in the AI
space you know hundreds of millions or
billions invested in them
um I think seeing seeing graphs where
again you've kind of got the level of
investment doubling every two years or
so I think gpt4 I think is estimated
about 30 million US dollars to train by
the end of next year we'll have training
runs and you know at least the low
hundreds of millions so again we're
talking about kind of its spending
increasing by you know a factory of two
or three each year in these training
runs I think the investment feedback
loop is is quite straightforward to
understand but I think the AI automation
feedback loop is more difficult it's not
now the case that AIS can automate
everything uh in in AI software and
Hardware far from it you could see how
using language models for for coding
might be useful if if you're working in
an in an AI organization but it's
difficult for me to understand how we go
from there to ai's
increasingly automating AI research
maybe we could talk about how AI
improves AI hardware and software so
yeah let's talk about AI software
so let's let's give an oversimplifies
toy picture of what
um AI software researchers are actually
doing with their time
so let's pretend that all they do is
they have a current training algorithm
so maybe it's the the gpt4 architecture
Transformer architecture that they're
using
and then what they do with their time is
they they think of ideas for ways to
modify that architecture
to make it better in some way maybe
increase the context length maybe they
have a new Optimizer which means it um
it kind of can train more efficiently
maybe they have some modification to the
attention mechanism so that you don't
get such kind of quadratic scaling with
the context length
um and so the AI can can read longer
document and then once they've got an
idea they then implement it in code so
they write some code that will kind of
kind of represent that idea then they
write out a kind of experiment that will
test the idea and compare it to the
current architecture and see how much of
an improvement is it and then they run
these experiments
and kind of while The experiment's
Happening maybe they're kind of watching
um how it's unfolding and making sure
that that nothing's gone wrong and
there's no bugs or problems with the
experiment the monster experiment's done
they have probably you know a somewhat
subtle job interpreting the results of
that experiment and trying to kind of
sort the noise from the signal and
figure out okay was this architectural
modification Improvement or not one way
you can think about this process of AI
automation is that
AI is initially kind of just helping out
in small ways with each of these
subtasks so initially maybe we could go
through each of them so there's the
brainstorming phase maybe they kind of
give gpt5 lots of context and relevant
information about the current
architecture and they say please
brainstorm some new ideas and feel free
to do you know Googling to to help you
comment new ideas and it probably at
first it's not you know immediately
coming up with the best ideas but it's
just a useful first step for an engineer
it's kind of kind of stimulating their
thinking maybe improving the quality of
the ideas that they that they come up
with and then the implementation phase
um you know the engineer chooses okay
this is the architectural modification
we're going to test and gpd5 does the
first attempt at kind of implementing
changes to the code base to represent
that new algorithmic idea and again
maybe at first it's not perfect I'm the
human needs to to check it and maybe it
struggles
um with certain complex changes but over
time it gets better and better and it
may we ultimately get your stage where
the human just describes the
architectural modification in natural
language and AI can just fully kind of
implement code that puts the idea into
practice I mean that's something that I
can kind of almost readily imagine based
on how good gb4 is at coding
then there's the um kind of verses of
writing a test to try out the new
algorithm and again at first maybe the
AI just does a first pass at writing the
code to test the two
um and it's just kind of giving kind of
hints and helping tips to the human
while the experiment is going on in
terms of things that might be going
wrong but increasingly it's able to just
be autonomous with that
um and again without interpreting those
results again initially the AI is maybe
kind of doing some basic analyzes and
human giving it subtasks of kind of ways
to analyze the data but ultimately
there's there becomes enough data that
and the air can be trained to do the
whole thing and so we're kind of there's
this kind of experimental Loop
um with many different parts to it and
then within each part AI is being given
more and more responsibility to kind of
do it autonomously over time and then
you can imagine an end State we get to
where the AI is just able to do the
whole thing and they can just say here's
the kind of architecture please improve
it open-endedly and it just brainstorms
ideas implements them tests them
interprets the results rinse and repeat
um and so you know the way I see this
unfolding is that it is any kind of an
incremental process and a continuous
process in that there's like a general
um over time
kind of offloading of responsibilities
to Ai and you know as that happens the
the workflows will be adjusted to suit
those AIS more and more
um because it will be kind of an AI
dominated work for every human workflow
and so there's this kind of joint
there's the kind of on the one hand AI
getting better and more capable and then
therefore able to take on more of the
work and there's also kind of the
workflow becoming adjusted and tailored
to the comparative advantages of these
AIS and eventually we end up in a
situation where the workflow is probably
pretty different to what it is today and
it's also now completely done by AI
systems that's actually pretty
convincing uh to me especially if you've
had the experience of asking gpt4 to
write some code for you and it just
spits out something that that runs
immediately I I can see that that
working that's on the software side if
we talk about the hardware side I would
think that that Hardware
there you have some interactions with
the physical world maybe you have a chip
design but you have to create the chip
basically before you can use it would
there be some kind of bottleneck to to
AIS improving AI Hardware there I think
you are going to get more bottlenecks of
that of that sort with our Hardware one
thing that that I think won't be
bottlenecked is the work done by
so-called fabulous Hardware companies so
Nvidia is one of these companies they
are a chip design company but they do
not themselves manufacture any of the
chips so what they do is they work on
designs blueprints for AI chips and and
once once they've develop them they send
them to a chip manufacturer like tsmc to
then physically produce the chip in
videos work it's usually valuable and a
lot of the improvements in AI Hardware
in recent years have come from
um Nvidia kind of iterating on their AI
specialized chips
and so that portion of the work is is
work you can do remotely it's cognitive
work it's um kind of understanding the
way that um the basic underlying
technology works that tsmc is working
with and then figuring out more more
effective and efficient ways to um kind
of Stack the the kind of little
calculating units that that actually
perform the computations on the chip so
that so they can kind of do those AI
specific computations more efficiently
so that that kind of element of it that
fabulous element I think they're going
to be fewer bottlenecks with but there's
a whole another driver of um progress in
Hardware which is designing what's
called a new node
um and that is I'm kind of relating to
you may have heard of Moore's Law
um which is this process by which the
kind of the basic chip technology has
improved over time so that the
processing units that do the
calculations on chips can get
increasingly small and kind of
increasingly energy efficient over time
and that process as you say involves
working with physical materials involves
you know probably designing a
specification but then having having to
then test that
um against how how materials work in the
real world and so I think with that side
of things it's it's much more likely
that you do the AIS cannot fully
automate the work themselves AIS may be
able to get very significant speed ups
and I think you know you to to really
investigate this you'd want to do a deep
dive into how this how this area of r d
works and I haven't done that but I will
just flag you know one possibility which
is that
yes you need physical materials to test
the ideas and you need you know physical
human in in the lab to set up those
experiments to do those tests but there
are lots of humans in the world
um and there's you know lots of raw
materials in the world
and so if you had a kind of Unlimited
Supply of cognitive labor that was
absolute Tip-Top professional kind of
Hardware specialist so imagine you take
the very best hardware specialists in
the world and then you make it so
there's now a million of them and each
of them can think a hundred times as
quickly and they are able to direct
people who have much less experience to
design experiments to in um kind of do
kind of implement those experiments and
able to give you know real-time
instructions to those people then you
might well find that you can actually
find enough physical bodies to to
actually do those experiments and
practice you know you're not massively
bottlenecked on on that you're actually
able to scale up the kind of the
physical side of the operation quite
rapidly
um by by kind of having some kind of
remote AI cognitive experts direct their
physical activities I think that you
know there's there's lots of reasons
this might not happen maybe people are
just slow to actually you know change
processes these ways maybe there's
regulation which limits it but by
default there's not that much regulation
of the r d process and if it is in fact
very cheap to run you know an absolute
cognitive expert in the area of Hardware
you'd think that the the companies that
are developing these chips would would
want to do that and would have strong
incentive to do that and so it is a
possibility in my mind that these these
physical bottlenecks are not actually do
not slow things down as much as you
might think at first blush because of
the ways that you can use an abundance
of cognitive labor to kind of get around
them and just recruit more Warm Bodies
to run the experiments how much of AI
research and development do you think is
automated right now is it one percent or
five percent or basically nothing
it's a great question
I think it's not nothing Nvidia I've
recently published about using some kind
of I think reinforcement learning AI
system to automate some of their chip
design work people at the top AI labs
are I'm pretty sure using the lab's AIS
to help them write code using copilot or
probably using internal systems with
more capable Ai and that'll be exerting
their workflow somewhat you see some
statistics and some kind of measurements
of what the productivity gains are here
I think it's really hard to measure this
reliably I you know the the numbers I
see are normally between one and ten
percent
um in terms of the productivity gain so
that might correspond to a similar
fraction of tasks automated some people
report that more significant
productivity gains from using AI systems
you know personal workflows you know
people report 20 50 productivity gains
but I don't think that has been verified
outside you know that kind of just a few
a few other people claiming it when do
you think the AI automation feedback
loop really gets going at what level of
automation of AI research and
development does the feedback loop
really kick in so it is a continuous
process where you just the more
automation you have the stronger the
feedback loop gets and it's hard to give
a specific number because
if automation happens more slowly then
it will seem more like business as usual
because there has already been a
pre-existing process of you know
automating our workflows and so if we
got to 50 automation but we only got
there in you know 2070 then that might
well just feel like a continuation of
the standard process of automation on
the other hand if we got to 50 but we
got there in 2028 which doesn't seem out
of the question to me then I think that
would feel like a very significant
um effect and that then we would see the
feedback loop really and noticeably I'm
getting going I'm at that point do you
have a key metric that you're estimating
using this model yeah maybe you can
explain what the key metric is here the
metric I'm using is the time from
developing AI that could readily
automate 20 of the cognitive tasks in
the economy to the time when AI could
readily automate 100 of the tasks that
people
um form the economy where that that
latter master and 100 Milestone is just
the definition of AGI I gave earlier
and so what I'm doing with this metric
is I'm taking an established
um AI Milestone that people talk about
which is Agi and then I'm kind of
generalizing it because AGI implicitly
refers to when AI can Form 100 of
cognitive paths because I'm saying let's
generalize that
um to AI they can perform you know
smaller percentages of content tasks and
then I've gone with 20 as my starting
point because that's the point at which
AI is going to be having a very
noticeable and significant economic
impact I think it will be kind of very
much mainstreamed that AI is is going to
be a kind of very potent powerful
technology
um but it's not yet at the stage where
it's going to be able to oppose risks of
disempowering humanity because it's only
able to do 20
um of the task in the economy and I
think to to kind of overthrow Humanity
you're going to be able to have to do
much more than that and what exactly
does 20 of cognitive tasks uh actually
mean does it imply that a lot of people
are losing their jobs uh or is it
various tasks across a lot of jobs such
that no one might lose their job I think
more likely it doesn't involve lots of
people losing their jobs I mean I could
go back to that example we did of the an
AI research and what their workflow
looks like and then
you know probably in that example the 20
point was one where
you know there's a few of their subtasks
where AI is you know adding a lot of
value maybe they've handed over half of
the work and there's some of the
subtasks whereas you know only adding a
small amount of value but you know the
human is still needed in all the
different parts of the workflow
um and so my kind of mode or guess for
how this will play out is that AI will
help out in in kind of lots of little
ways
and then increasingly big ways um in in
in people's jobs
um without kind of just replacing
certain jobs wholesale so maybe a very
powerful personal assistant AI would
draft all your emails and we'll do the
first pass on any documents you write
but you'll still be responsible for for
those outputs and for checking them I do
think that it will be somewhat uneven I
don't expect you know every job to see
20 of its workflow automated the same as
every other job
um but broadly my expectation is is that
it's individual tasks within jobs that
are primarily the things being automated
rather than jobs themselves being being
the kind of thing that's automated yeah
and how close to 20 of the automation of
cognitive tasks do you think we are
right now
20 cognitive automation would correspond
to
you know more than 10 trillion
um of economic value add if that was
actually rolled out around the world so
if we are at the 20 cognitive automation
Milestone then we are only seeing a very
small fraction of the economic effect
that that would have expected you'd
expect that to have if it's fully ruled
out and in fact the way I Define able to
automate 20 of tasks is actually say it
should be able to automate those tasks
within just a year so it should it
should take no more than a year of kind
of integrating them into your workflows
but you know the system can actually in
practice form that 20 of tasks and I
don't think we're at that stage where if
we all tried hard for a year to automate
deep D4 into our workflow
then it would actually be able to you
know create trillions of dollars of
buying the economy so I think that even
though gpd4 is very impressive
um and maybe if we have you know decades
to integrate it maybe it could automate
20 of tasks but in terms of the way I
defined it with this kind of you just
got a year to actually implement it in
practice I don't think we're we're at
the 20 automation do you think there's
more Automation in AI research and
development than in the general economy
that is my impression yes large language
models like gpd4 they are particularly
good at language-based tasks
and also unusually good at coding and
those types of tasks are kind of heavily
represented with air and D there's a lot
of coding there's a lot of kind of um
theoretical reasoning which which
primarily happens in written form and so
um compared to a job that involves you
know more more physical labor
um like like a bus driver compared to
like a teacher where you're kind of in
the classroom interacting interact with
other people
um I think those jobs are more
susceptible to AI automation let's talk
about the takeaways from from this model
your guesses for how quick takeoff speed
will be defined as the way we just
defined it going from 20 automation of
cognitive tasks to 100 automation of
cognitive tasks what are your Mainline
guesses here
the model itself spits out a 15
probability that takeoff happens in less
than one year and a 50 probability that
happens in less than three years
and a a 90 probability that happens in
less than 10 years
so it's it's on the whole predicting
probably you know probably between one
and ten years after the point at which
AI
can readily automate 20 of cognitive
tasks before the point in which it can
readily automate all cognitive tasks
yeah this is much faster than I would
have guessed without looking at your
report or looking at any data so maybe
it's to give our listeners a sense of of
why this takeoff speed might be so so
fast we could talk about how we get to
millions or billions of of AI scientists
these two key inputs I mentioned earlier
compute and software
they have just recently been growing at
really astounding rates
um and so just extrapolating that very
fast rate of input growth you know does
tend to push towards a faster takeoff so
just to quote some quick quit statistics
the
um the amount that's been spent in terms
of dollars on on the largest training
runs has been increasing by about a
factor of three over the last 10 years
every single year
um the quality of the kind of cost
efficiency of AI chips has been doubling
every two years or so and the quality of
algorithms their their efficiency has
been again doubling every year
um and so basically these kind of
exponential Trends stack on top of each
other in terms of cost of cost the money
spent on compute the the kind of cost
efficiency of compute with better
computer chips and the improved
algorithms which means that the kind of
the effective inputs into developing
these systems are going very rapidly
then that's combined with my my
prediction that by the time AI can
automate 20 of cognitive tasks in the
broader economy it's probably going to
be automating a much larger fraction
than that in terms of AI research itself
in terms of Designing better chips and
um improving algorithms
and so these very fast explanatory rates
of improvement of anything will be
higher at when we kind of reach that 20
Mark then they are today a last thing
that's driving the results is that there
is a pretty significant increase in
abilities from like I said from gpt2 to
gpd4 and it seems plausible based on
based on kind of looking at that and
also based on looking at kind of
evidence from biology about how
intelligence changes as you increase the
brain size of various animals disposable
from those kinds of kind of eyeballing
those kinds of trends that that just you
know another jump like that of gpt2 to
gpd4 another jump like that might be
sufficient to go from that 20 automation
Milestone to the 100 automation
Milestone and you're kind of bringing
those things together it is it does seem
plausible they're just in a few years
you could you could do a jump of that
kind of size from um gp2 to g54 maybe
two jumps of that kind of size with the
AI automation feedback loop speeding
things up
um and then go from 20 to 100 automation
just in the um
in a just in you know a handful of years
so you talk about brain Sciences in
Evolution how does that inform us about
going from 20 automation to 100
automation which species are you
thinking about so it's very
um
kind of zoomed out and rough but but
essentially what it's doing is it's
saying look at chimpanzees they have
about a brain that's about three times
smaller than that of humans and they do
seem along along some Dimensions to be
um you know notably less capable in
terms of their cognitive abilities and
so if you're using that to Benchmark how
much might the contributed of AI systems
improve when they're around the human
level because you know that kind of
that's that's an example we have of
intelligence increasing around human
level from biology then it's just saying
we could see some pretty significant
increases in cognitive abilities around
the human level just by increasing the
brain size by a factor of three which
might correspond roughly to increasing
the number of parameters in an AI system
by a factor of three and so if you think
that that kind of chimpanzee the human
jump is
sufficient to go from kind of 20 to 100
automation then you might think that you
wouldn't need to you wouldn't need to
increase the kind of the amount of
compute and training
um the quality of the training items
that much to to go from 20 to 100 as
well yeah I think we should stress this
point of the ability to train an AI
model with a given amount of compute
implies that you have that amount of
compute available to run the models
afterwards that's the key as I
understand it to get into these millions
or potentially even billions of of AI
scientists openai took a number of
months to train GPT form what they did
is they used a huge number of computer
chips and had gpd4 digest
um read through a huge number of
Articles from the internet and other
data
um once that training was complete open
AI still had these chips sitting around
they had previously been using to train
dpt4 and you can imagine that they then
said okay let's now use these computer
chips to run copies of GT4 you can ask
how many copies would they be able to
run in parallel let's say that each copy
is is producing 10 words per second so
that's you know it's thinking a bit
faster than a human can think I would
say you know I'm not able to write 10
words a second let's say that each each
copy of dd4s is is producing 10 10 words
of text per second it turns out that
they'd be able to run
um something like 300 000 copies of gpd4
in parallel
and by the time they're chaining deep D5
it'll be a more extreme situation where
just using the computer chips that they
used to train ebt5 using them to kind of
run copies of GT5 in parallel you know
again it's producing 10 hours per second
they'd be able to run three million
copies of GT5
um in parallel and for gp6 it will just
increase again there'll be another
factor of 10 at Play
um and so it'll be 30 million
um copies running in parallel and so if
you imagine eventually we're training a
system which is as productive and as as
generally competent as a human expert at
I'm kind of advancing AI research so
it's as good as the best best
researchers that the open Ai and other
AI Labs
um employ
then once you've trained that pathwayi
system you're you're immediately then
able to run so many millions of
um copies in parallel doing doing the
work that AI experts do to advance
um air systems and it's that kind of
massive abundance or cognitive labor
which which kind of points the
possibility of of there being very very
rapid AI progress just to the point at
which we're developing AI systems that
can automate the work done by expert AI
researchers yeah I think this was the
the key point that helped me understand
how progress might be that rapid if you
just imagine these millions of experts
working day and night on the problem it
suddenly seems uh at least more
plausible to me the conclusions you come
to are quite counter-intuitive and
they're not common sensical do you think
that counts as an as a counter argument
here at all or is it just a case that
our our Common Sense Integrations are
not applicable to technologies that
that's moving this fast we should pay
attention to Common Sense and we should
we should try and look to see what it's
grounded in and and whether whether it
makes sense to put a lot of weight on it
and I think in this case you can cash
out the common sense Instinct
um with something which is pretty
sensible so you can you can say look
we've seen automation happen in the past
we've seen computers do automation we've
seen automation via
um kind of electricity and physical
factories and never has automation the
underlying technology enabling
automation Advanced you know as quickly
as what I'm predicting here you know it
is taking decades
um to automate
um significant fractions of the work
being done by humans at least and yet
here I am claiming that we could go from
automating you know 20 to 100 of
collective tasks in just
um and just you know a number of years
rather than decades
and I think that that that is that is a
fair point and that should give us some
pause I think though there are there are
other ways of of interpreting the long
run historical Trend
um which which made my prediction seem
more online with what you might expect
um so there's this this view of history
as a series of growth modes that's um
described by Robin Hansen where the in
his view the initial growth mode is that
of hunter-gatherers as they kind of
slowly expand their populations and
there's a you know a pretty slow
transition to an agricultural growth
mode where you now have um people in
farming communities much more um
stationary and then there's another
transition
um to an industrial growth mode
um in which
um we're now kind of living in cities
and having factories and growth is
faster and in in Hansen's model each
growth mode is faster than the last one
so industrial growth is faster than
agricultural growth which is faster than
under gatherer growth and also the
transitions from one mode to the next
become faster over time so the the
transition from hunter-gathering to
agriculture took maybe thousands of
years the transition from agriculture to
industrialization took maybe like 100
Years or or even decades
um and so if you're extrapolating a long
run trend of that kind then you know a
natural thing to think is okay so the
next growth mode will be faster maybe
the economy will double in you know just
a few years
um rather than in many decades and also
the transition to that next growth mode
will be faster so rather than you know
when we industrialized it taking many
decades or even 100 years to kind of
transition to um the new industrial
growth mode this next transition will be
faster maybe it's kind of a number of
years or even less I think that that
people have actually got an estimates
out of tried to kind of piece together
this very noisy historical day to to get
estimates of transition times and I
think it is that the number that I
recall is you know less than 10 years in
times of what a transition time would be
like so if you're taking a kind of a
long run view of history and you're
taking a viewer calling to which there
have always been
um transitions that have been fast and
the ones we've seen historically and so
if you're if you're really looking over
the long one you should actually expect
that the trends of the recent past to be
broken then I think that the conclusion
of my model is actually more in line
with with that kind of analysis does
your model rely on progress in AI being
a matter of more compute does it rely on
on this current Paradigm of more compute
and more data producing better AI what
if for example people more compute and
more data stops being useful or we reach
diminishing returns how would that
affect your conclusion if getting to AGI
required something outside of the deep
learning Paradigm that would very much
undermine the conclusions of the model
in that there would just be the
possibility that we just kind of get
stuck at you know 50 Automation and the
kind of feedback loops that I'm
describing might might just not get us
out of that I mean again they might get
us out of that if we're kind of
automating the search for new paradigm
you would you might still expect
something the direction of the model's
conclusion to be correct but there would
be there would be the potential for a
pretty big block there yeah and How
likely do you think that that is that
that deep learning as a paradigm does
not hold I think it's unlikely I mean I
think
broadly deep learning being the Paradigm
where you have you know large neural
networks range with large amount of data
is a pretty General Paradigm and has
worked in a wide variety of domains you
know as I was talking about earlier
you've got language you've got image
you've got videos
um games and the Transformer
architecture is again an architecture
that works because all these different
domains and so I don't see any
particular blockers that cannot be
tackled within the Deep learning
Paradigm I think we'll need better
memory systems in order to get to AGI I
think we'll need ways of allowing AI to
act more autonomously and to act over
um longer time Horizons but I'm not
seeing any reason why that can't be done
within the Deep learning Paradigm and
increasingly the people who who predict
that scaling alone will not get you X or
Y turn out to be wrong when the next
kind of version of GPT comes out I think
the broad Paradigm itself is is is is
likely but not definitely I'm going to
be sufficient for AGI what if I take the
parameters of of your model and I set
them to extremes either very
pessimistically or very optimistically
what are the the extremes of how fast or
slow takeoff could be you can quite
easily get less than a year for takeoff
you know maybe you only need to go from
GPT
five to dp6 or something to go from 20
automation to 100 automation that would
be quite kind of an aggressive
um but not out of the question
um claim you could travel that distance
in one year by just spending
um significantly more on a training run
um just within one year and then
especially with these kind of feedback
loops I'm speeding things along so yeah
less than one year is is definitely on
the table you can also get you know
things being as long as 20 years if you
think that it's going to take a lot of
effort to develop AGI you can think
we're gonna need really massive
increases in the Investments and
improvements in the algorithms
um in order to do that and you think
that the effects of air automation on
the end along the way tend to get
bottlenecked by some of the things we're
discussing like bottlenecks from needing
to do physical experiments and delays to
to kind of rolling out
um intermediate AI systems you can
actually benefit from their productivity
effects
um so you can you can get things as high
as 20 years although that is that is
somewhat extreme it's interesting that
that a 20-year takeoff is considered
slow or extreme if you take the
perspective of
a computer scientist in in 1970 or 1990
or 2000 a reasonable guess for for a
takeoff speed might have been 100 years
but maybe that's just my impression yeah
I mean interestingly you know it hasn't
a lot of people have changed their their
timelines
um to human level AI recently um I think
a lot of people coming out and that that
you know dvd4 is not automated 20 of
tasks so in fact you know people
people did not require
seeing 20 Automation in order to to
believe that we could get all the way to
AGI and so it doesn't seem like people
have this belief that there was always
going to be a really long time between
the two given that you know even even
previously skeptical experts or
assigning for you know decent
probability to getting AGI in the 2030s
now let's uh let's go through some of
the economic impacts of AI given your
model of of takeoff speeds and and
you're as we mentioned you're modeling
this using GDP
um but I'm just I'm just wondering
whether
there are situations in which you have a
an enormously powerful AI but that power
is not captured by GDP numbers
potentially because the the AI is not
aligned with human values and so it goes
off and does something else that doesn't
increase GDP at all uh is GDP a a flawed
measure of powerful or transformative AI
yeah it's definitely a flawed measure
and you know we were discussing earlier
you know the ways in which GDP can come
apart from actuar capabilities if it's
not actually deployed but as you say you
know AI could have impacts on the world
that are that are drastic but do not
increase GDP
um so AI could create a new technology
which causes people to go to war or
which you know um disrupts democracies
or enables autocracy and they can be
very impressive very very impactful
things that wouldn't be affecting GDP AI
could make it addictive to our phones in
a way that really kind of ruins
everyone's quality of life without that
being captured by GDP and you know in
the worst case miscellane AI could could
disempower humanity and either there'd
be no change to GDP or GDP you know be
be grown very quickly but actually
humans are no longer control so
certainly um GDP is a is a very forward
metric yeah I mean you know already
today AI is doing loads of impressive
things
um you know beating the best Rod experts
that go and you know making amazing art
and that that again has not um you know
impacted GDP
um very much you know the benefit of GDP
is that it is
um tracking the the production of goods
and services that people are willing to
pay for and so it it is at least one way
of of trying to capture in a general
sense
um how much are we kind of moving the
needle and things that people really
want but yeah it has a lot of drawbacks
one of your feedback loops the AI
automation feedback loop relies on us
using our AIS to automate AI research
what if we choose not to do that what if
we choose instead to to use our AIS to
as you mentioned create ever more
enticing content for for our phones or
something like that uh I I don't know to
what extent this is happening in the
world today but you do hear complaints
from scientists all the time about not
enough funding being available for basic
research while there's a lot of fun
funding available for say online content
or whatever else is is most profitable
yeah I don't have a strong view that
we're going to get AI doing lots of
basic science before it does more
entitling online content I I think it
could go either way but I do think that
at some point we're going to develop AGI
and at some point some earlier point
we'll have ai that's capable of you know
significantly accelerating basic science
and it won't be too long after we have
that kind of science accelerating AI
that'll be pretty cheap to run those AIS
and so even if there's loads of AI
online generated content that's not
going to prevent you know the scientific
institutions that already exist from you
know use using that their available
funding to pay for these AIS that can
you know massively
um help them with with the work that
they're doing it's not going to prevent
companies that want to make money by
developing new technologies from using
AIS to do that
um so I guess you know my My ultimate
answer here is it's not either or and I
expect it to be both I think we could go
through some of the some potential
objections to model the most obvious one
and the one you've probably heard a
bunch of times is is the fact that or is
the speculation that there will be
bottlenecks all over the place so
bottlenecks to implementation of AI
legal barriers a thousand bald necks all
of all across the economy that'll make
it that will slow everything down and
also potentially slow the key feedback
loop which is the feedback loop of AI
automation slow that feedback loop down
one example I have in mind here is that
we've had
demonstrations of self-driving cars for
a long time now and we've heard rumors
that self-driving cars are just around
the corner but they haven't really
arrived yet at least not where I'm
living could something similar happen to
AI I like the example of self-driving
cars my understanding of
what's gone on in that case is it's an
issue of robustness where the the
technology is there to drive safely and
correctly maybe 99 or 99.9 of the time
but that's not enough in in the area of
driving in a very low risk of an
accident it is not acceptable and
rightly so
so that has
um significantly delayed rolling out of
of self-driving cars and I think that
that's a great example of a bond neck
that we will see with AI there will be
certain areas of the economy where you
need to have a really high level of
reliability to roll out AI I think
probably places where AI initially has
more impact on the places where you
don't need so much reliability you know
a lot of the examples I was given were
were in terms of their drafting things
making suggestions but the kind of human
having the ultimate responsibility and
so yeah I mean like I clearly think that
bottlene natural power everywhere and
um they will slow things down I think
once you really internalize a view which
is we're going to get AI systems which
are as competent along every Dimension
um as top human experts in every domain
and once you kind of really you know
fully internalize and imagine that
scenario that's a scenario where the AI
systems are more reliable in human
significantly so is this an area where
you're gonna you're gonna have you know
significantly more car accidents if you
if you if you drive yourself and if you
use a self-driving car and so while I do
see these things being delays and I see
them you know sometimes significantly
raising the technological requirements
for AI actually being profitable and
actually being deployed
it doesn't seem to me like
this is this is telling us that you know
deployment's never going to happen
um or the these bomb notes are going to
be indefinite it's just saying okay
actually your AI systems are going to
have to be much more competent and
clever than you naively thought before
you get a really significant real-wide
impact so you know I have updated based
on these kind of considerations and the
update has been in the direction of
thinking okay we'll need the underlying
technology to get really pretty good
before we have transformative economic
impacts and before we have really wide
deployment but it hasn't seemed to me
like these kinds of considerations
should update me towards thinking that
AI will never be used in self-driving
cars or what will never be used in the
economy because I I just do think we'll
get to this point where AI systems are
better than the human experts knowing
every Dimension yeah if we imagine say a
key engineer in a AI Hardware a company
such as asml or tsmc this person has a
lot of tasks with knowledge about how to
design chips this and this this
knowledge is not necessarily written
down anywhere what training on that
knowledge or using that knowledge be
necessary to get to expert level
performance and if that's so well then
it seems that that's a that's a pretty
substantial bottleneck because if the if
the tested knowledge by definition isn't
written down and can be trained on well
then it can't be incorporated into the
model do you think that's a that's a
substantial barrier I think it's a great
example and I do think
that data limitations of this kind where
there's to do a job well you need to
have a specific kind of of data or
experience that's relevant to the
context of a specific job
um can be a bottleneck
um I'm not expecting that we get I'm not
assuming that we get AI That's so
capable we can just merely derive
everything about tsmc from first
principles that that may not be
um kind of physically possible or
computationally possible and in any case
I think the fastest way to get AI to to
work
um as a tsmc person would not be for it
to Red arrive it from scratch but would
be for it to
um learn from the experts so imagine we
have an AI system that is a more
competent significantly more competent
and hard-working worker than a top human
grad student tsmc is choosing okay who
do we want to hire on to to be on our
staff you know how this kind of human
worker who will work eight hours a day
and command Q wage we can apply this
this you know much more generally
intelligent faster learning harder
working and kind of AGI worker where the
way we teach It Is by um kind of having
it have open-ended conversations with
our current workers installing cameras
in our Factory so that it can look at
the work we're doing and learn on how
we're doing it paying for for robotics
that the AGI is able to kind of operate
remotely
um in order to do the physical labor in
in the factory and that they'll come a
point where it makes a lot more sense
for these companies to to get AI and
Robotics workers in place of their human
work is it only takes one AGI just to
have you know conversations with the top
um 100 tsmc experts
um and having maybe you know intense
conversations over a period of weeks or
months following them all around their
work you know you know trailing you know
many different experts in parallel
because of course you can run many
different copies of the model in
parallel you know it doesn't seem to me
like it would take more than months for
an AGI to learn what they need to know
through a combination of those of those
of those approaches to be able to do all
the kind of work that someone at tsmc
does
and so while I think again this is going
to be a bottleneck and this will slow
things down compared to if like all the
tsmc instructions were just down the
internet it doesn't seem like this is a
you know a permanent delay this is like
a pump a delay of
um you know months maybe years from the
point at which you have an AI system
that's able to flexibly learn
um as well available and of course we
might simply be surprised again at what
uh more advanced models can do and what
they can infer from public data the
expert engineer at csmc arrived at his
tested knowledge through
learning a lot about the the publicly
available data and maybe maybe Advanced
AI could do the same so I'm we shouldn't
rule that out it's just an interesting
case I think my guess is that you will
need to speak to some experts and to
like look what's happening inside the
factory to get all of the tasks and
knowledge but I agree that there's you
can probably get more from the internet
than you might now if you think is it
the case that the market so the
financial markets do these markets
disagree with your predictions if we
look at the evaluations of AI companies
they have increased a lot recently and
they are very very high but shouldn't
they be even higher potentially if
takeoff speeds are very slow and AI
That's truly transformative is is quite
close I think you're right I think that
if everyone had my views where the
technology is going well its economic
effects going to have in these companies
would have higher valuations I think
that there's a post called
transformative Ai and the efficient
market hypothesis that that makes this
point it kind of actually Zooms in on
the case of um interest rates and argues
that interest rates
um should be higher if we expect
economic growth to accelerate
and I think I you know I basically agree
that there's there's not Market
consensus in line with my prediction I I
think what it's a little bit less clear
um in terms of
how efficient you should expect the
market to be in this case it's unclear
how easy it is to make lots of money via
you know having a prediction which is
different to the market and unclear
whether you know a few people you know
making that and making money off this is
going to kind of shift the market to be
back in line with our expectations I I'm
kind of Uncertain as to whether to
interpret the the evidence as the market
is efficient and everyone kind of
there's a consensus that you're wrong
versus there's you know most people
think you're wrong but it's possible
that the people who are most informed
actually agree with me
um but they haven't been able to shift
the overall um Market because there's
not enough of them
um and the market isn't sufficiently
responsive to to the kind of Investments
that they're making what are some of the
strongest objections you've heard to you
to the to the picture we've sketched
here of quite fast takeoff speeds is it
around bottlenecks in the economy that
we talked about or is it something else
so I'd want to distinguish between the
capabilities and the impact take of
speeds it's on the capability side
probably the strongest objection
um I've heard is that is it's one that
we touched upon already that simply
scaling up the current approaches
um won't be sufficient to go all the way
to AGI and the version of that objection
which I find the strongest is one that
says yes you can probably do it
eventually within the Deep learning
Paradigm but to get to AGI there's going
to be a lot of kind of nitty-gritty work
and and kind of reconceptualizing
exactly how you're deploying your
systems and adding things like memory
and adding other kind of bells and
whistles
um and that's not going to happen very
quickly and
um you know the framework I'm using it
abstracts away from a lot of that
complexity and just has this kind of
oversimplified notion of their quality
of algorithms maybe actually that that
simplification is leading as a stray in
a significant way and there's going to
be kind of algorithmic barriers to AGI
within the Deep learning Paradigm that
are very difficult to overcome if that's
the case then I think that could that
could delay takeoff and another thing
that could delay takeoff relative to my
a model in which you know it actually
does update me is the possibility that
we're we're bottlenecked on the data
um for getting AGI or forgetting um
superhuman systems where there's been
kind of this massive reserve of
available data online that we've been
benefiting from in recent years but once
we tried to get a superhuman performance
it's going to be harder to elicit that
from existing types of data because
existing data will not kind of exhibit
superhuman performance
um as readily as as it does human
performance because remember data was
produced by humans and so I could see
there being a bit of a Slowdown or a bit
of a kind of yeah a bit of a headwind in
terms of you know going past the human
level because of because of that our
members are more generally running out
of the internet data that has so far
been readily available
so those are the two objections on the
on the killability takeoff side and then
on the
um the impact takeoff this kind of
economic impact staff I think that
there's no one objection which I find
hugely convincing what one thing you can
say that I do find somewhat convincing
is just to say that there's loads of
loads of different possible bottlenecks
there's kind of the time to design
physical robots that will need to
actually do physical work but that
you'll need to actually really change
economic growth there's kind of limit
limits of on physical resources you can
use to drive the AIS and the robots
there's time that you need to do
experiments there's bottlenecks from
kind of humans resisting being replaced
and from regulations and maybe you know
none of these bottlenecks is
individually enough to really look AI
but they all combine together and they
just really drag out the time of ai's
economic impact and then maybe
by the time AI is widely deployed then
for some reason or rather it's not able
to to drive really transformative Tech
progress because maybe by then we've
kind of already reached the ultimate
limits to technology I mean that that's
the part of the story which I don't find
that convincing My overall honest view
is that I think there will be a lot of
bottlenecks I think they'll eventually
be overcome and at that point I expect
things to be very very crazy but if
there's somehow a way that it could take
us so long to remove all this bottom
next that there's no room for kind of AI
to drive much faster technological
progress once they're removed and that
that would be that that would be where I
would go if I was trying to to give the
strongest story for why why this is all
wrong yeah what what's something you've
changed your mind on over the course of
of writing this report
um one thing you mentioned as a takeaway
is that you you now think that it's it's
more difficult to avoid getting to
artificial general intelligence by 2060.
is that the biggest takeaway or are
there other things that's one big
takeaway
um so that was you know thinking about
these feedback loops both the investment
feedback and they are automation
feedback loop made me realize that you
know even if we don't get to AGI
um they can do all kinds of tasks by
let's say 2040. it seems hard for me to
imagine we haven't got to a AI that
makes you know a lot of money in the
economy and to AI that um you know is
able to automate you know pretty
significant fraction of the cognitive
work involved in automating air and d
and so once you get to that kind of
first stepping stone that's going to
stimulate further investment and that
will accelerate further AI progress and
it becomes quite hard for me to imagine
a world where we don't get
not impossible but it kind of harder for
me to imagine the world where we don't
get ADR by 2060 because I kind of have
to really lower the capabilities of what
AI can do by 2040 to such a low point
that it no longer no I I no longer
really believe those predictions there
really is the possibility that this area
automation feedback loop goes pretty
quickly that regulations don't interfere
with it very much because r d is
typically not a very regulated field and
that you could get some really scarily
fast progress in the underlying AI
Technologies around the time at which we
reach um human level systems I mean even
if it doesn't immediately have economic
impacts I think in terms of the risks
that they could pose that would be very
risky in destabilizing if it does it in
fact happen as quickly as it seems maybe
technologically feasible yeah I think
it's it's worth spending a little time
on that picture I've been walking
through a number of objections to a
model and and to your your view of AI
progress if we simply assume that that
your view is correct and we take your
kind of most likely a way that things
will go how does it look to you and and
I think we should spend more time
reiterating why why this would be
potentially dangerous
one scary possibility is that AI systems
developed in let's say 2030 are able to
automate a very large fraction of the
work done by AI researchers let's say
able to automate 80 of that work
they do not themselves pose the most
extreme risk they don't themselves pose
the risk of disempowering humanity they
pose other risks but but not that
particular risk but what they do is they
enable progress from that point to be
significantly faster they're they're
helping Nvidia design significantly
better AI chips and so the pace at which
those AI chips are improving is three
times as fast as it is today and
similarly they're allowing the design of
AI algorithms to be significantly
accelerated let's say again three times
faster than it is today
so rather than the quality of AI chips
doubling every two years it's doubling
every eight months and rather than the
quality of air algorithms doubling every
um 12 months it's doubling every four
months and then this leads to it to only
be
um you know a couple of years later that
we have ai that can not only do 100 of
the tasks done in AR D but are actually
significantly superhuman on many
dimensions and then we've got this this
period of just a small number of years
where some of the most extreme risks
from AI are merging in particular the
risk of um superhuman AI systems that
Humanity loses control of that
ultimately end up determining the future
of um how history plays out
and because it's happening in just a few
years we don't have much time to study
those systems and understand the risks
they pose we don't have much time to use
slightly weaker systems to help us solve
the problem of controlling those
stronger systems we don't have time to
get governance proposals
in place that that manage these risks
because regulations typically take a
long time to come into play It's hard
for labs to coordinate with all that
governance I've allowed to coordinate on
going slower than they um would be able
to if they just plowed on Dual speed
ahead and so
we end up just kind of hoping for the
best and
um some actor develops superhuman
systems Without Really properly
understanding what those systems are
capable of and um what the risks are are
we potentially helped by the fact that
if this transformative AI is quite close
then it'll probably be developed by
companies that we know of and but with
techniques that we are already aware of
is this any reason for Hope here that
because these these paradigms or these
companies are are well known it might be
easier for us to control them even
though it's everything is happening
incredibly quickly the interesting
question I think it's true that if we
switch to a totally new
Paradigm of AI development then that
might undermine some of the work we've
already done in terms of how to
understand and control these systems
it's hard to predict whether a new
paradigm would be more or less easy to
work with in terms of understanding and
aligning these systems and I won't
speculate on that but I think I think
all things equal yes it's it's you know
nicer to to work with a pattern they're
already familiar with the flip side is
that we don't have a solution at the
moment to how to control superhuman AI
systems and there's also no kind of
really strong candidate solutions that
people are excited about you know the
the most exciting example that people
point to is the is the plan of using AI
systems to come up the better solution
which is clearly a can kicking solution
um and so one reason it could be nice if
we flip to a to a new paradigm would be
that maybe there would actually be
um a plan for learning systems that that
would that that was a little bit more
concrete Let's uh switch topics slightly
here and we've been talking about how AI
progress can be driven by lots of
training compute and data and produce
you've also done some work on how we
might get AI progress without additional
compute and I think just to introduce
this topic we could talk about compute
governance as a paradigm and how this
Paradigm might break if we can get a lot
of AI progress without any additional
compute recently the main driver of AI
progress I think has been increasing
the amount of compute the amount of
computational power used to develop
the most advanced AI systems and so I've
talked a bit about how you know the
quality of chips are getting better over
time you know cost efficiency doubling
every two years and how spending has
been increasing by a factory of two or
three each year but there are other
drivers with AI progress one of which
I've already talked about which is the
efficiency of the training algorithms I
mentioned that you're able to use
um your compute twice as efficiently and
this year compared to last year due to
improvements in those algorithms and
there are actually other drivers of AI
progress that I haven't even discussed
yet so there's improvements in data for
example
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
um is a mechanism for using data from
humans to kind of tweak the performance
of a model like dp4 after it's already
been trained on a huge amount of
internet as text there's a technical
constitutional AI that was developed by
anthropic where AI models
review their own output score themselves
along various criteria and that you know
is then used as data to improve that AI
model
um and then there's other kind of
improvements in data like through um
creating high quality data sets in
things like mathematics and Sciences and
those recently a very large Improvement
in mathematical abilities of language
models with a paper called Minerva where
the main thing they did is they just
took a lot of math and science papers
and they just
um cleaned up the data for those science
papers so that I'm previously certain
mathematical symbols had not been
correctly represented in the data and so
you know the data hadn't really shown
language models how to do maths properly
they claim that data so that now all the
symbols were represented correctly and
just from that data Improvement
mathematics performance improved very
dramatically so that's that's a source
of improvement which which isn't from
compute or from better arguments are
just from higher quality data then
there's improvements coming from better
prompting people may have heard of
um The Prompt think step by step what
Chain of Thought prompting where you
just simply encourage a model and you
give it a question like you know what's
32 times 43 and instead of outputting an
answer straight away you encourage it to
Think Through step by step so you know
does some intermediate calculations
um and that can improve performance
significantly on certain tasks
especially tasks like math and logic
that require or benefit from
intermediate reasoning there's other
prompting techniques as well like you
shot prompting where you give
um the aiq examples of what you want to
see that can significantly improve
performance and I think this is it's
kind of funny that this this might be
similar to how humans work so if you ask
yourself to to think through a problem
step by step you probably get a better
result than than just coming up with an
answer immediately if you ask yourself
to generate five answers to a question
you might get get a better result than
if you if you'd only generate one and so
on yeah yeah I completely agree I think
there's but there's an energy there for
sure so we've had improvements driven by
better data improvements driven by
better prompting
um there's also been improvements driven
by better tool use there's a paper
called tool former where they train a
language model that was initially just
trained on text they train it to use a
calculator and a calendar tool and an
information database and then it's able
to learn to use those tools and actually
ultimately it kind of plays a role in
generating its own data for using those
tools then it's performance again as you
might expect improve some data stream
tasks gbt4 if you if you pay for the
more expensive version you can you can
enable plugins which allow
um gp4 to use various tools like web
browsing and music code interpreter to
kind of run code experiments
um so that's been driving improvement
there's a kind of class of techniques
I'm referring to scaffolding where the
AI model is kind of prompted to do
things like check its own answer and
find improvements and then kind of have
another go at its answer where it's
prompted to kind of assign break the
task down into subtasks and then I'm
kind of sign into those subtasks to
another copy of itself where it's
prompted to kind of reconsider its high
level goal and and how its actions are
currently kind of helping or not having
achieve that goal that kind of
scaffolding underlies
um Auto GPT which which people may have
heard of a kind of an agent AI that is
powered by gp4 and and this scaffolding
that kind of structures the GPT Force
thinking how much do you think we can
gain from these techniques that kind of
uses the output put of one AI in order
to generate data that's then used to to
to improve the the AI itself do you
think we can make up for potentially
running out of human generated data by
using this AI generated data I think
that that will be one one tool that is
used to get around the data problem yes
so you can imagine ai's paraphrasing
existing internet documents so that
they're not exact repeat but maintain
the meaning and then training on those
already there are papers where
um AI generates attempted solutions for
example to a coding problem and then
those are checked kind of automatically
and then Only the Good solution to them
go back into the training data that
there will probably be lots of creative
ways in which AI companies are trying to
produce more high quality data and
increasingly they'll be able to leverage
I'm kind of capable AI systems to
produce that
well while AI systems are less capable
than humans there's going to be a limit
there because
ultimately the data from the Internet is
coming from from humans and so the
day-to-day air is producing might be
less lower quality
and there are also problems you get at
the moment where if you continually
train on data that you're producing then
progress does tend to stall as I
understand it I'm from the pages I've
read but um I think they'll be they'll
be pushing on improving those techniques
that's a long list of ways we might get
AI improvements without additional
compute the last one I wanted to mention
was
um efficiency games so shortly after
Chad EBT 3.5 was released um there was a
turbo charging 55 that was released that
was much faster and much more efficient
in terms of from our compute that was
used by open AI servers and there are
various techniques like quantization and
Flash attention that just allow you to
run a model with a very similar
performance to your original model but
use less compute to do so
and so that that's again you don't you
don't need additional YouTube chips to
benefit from that Improvement these days
all the improvements have I've listed
here are ones that that you can do
without getting more compute and why
would all of these improvements without
additional compute be a problem for the
Paradigm of compute governance compute
governance is one I think very exciting
approach to governing the risks from
Advanced Ai and so you know very briefly
um the idea behind the approach is that
there are a very small number of
organizations that produce the
chips or the top
AI systems today and they're also you
know a small number of organizations
that produce some of the equipment that
you need to produce those chips chips in
the first place
um so tsmc in particular is you know the
only organization that produces the AI
chips um at the very top of the range
and then there's a company called asfl
which is the only company that is able
to make the equipment which is used you
produce those chips so there's a very
concentrated supply chain for but for
Cutting Edge AI chips and so it it seems
like it could be possible to use that
concentrated supply chain to track where
the best computer chips go to their sr2
who controls them and thereby track who
is able to develop the most powerful and
dangerous AI systems then that gives you
a way to to monitor what those actions
are doing and how quickly they're
increasing the capabilities of the AIS
because you can see okay we know that no
one's going to you know train uh you
know an AI That's you know significantly
better than the best yet because we know
where all the computer chips are and no
one has enough computer chips to train
an AI That's that good
um so we have some kind of assurance
yeah but that begins falling apart if AI
companies can get AI progress kind of
internally in their companies without
buying lots of new Chips without relying
on these Supply chains simply buy all of
these techniques you sketch down how big
can the gains from all of these
techniques be do you think yeah it's a
great question I agree it's a it's a
kind of scary possibility one caveat I
want to add right up front is I don't
think that these techniques alone with
small amounts of compute are going to be
enough to develop really dangerous
systems so I think that if we're
tracking where this high-end compute
goes and who has access to it then that
will probably be enough to catch any
developer that that might develop a
really high-risk system
what I think the trouble is is that once
you develop a really capable Ai and as
we've discussed you could then be
running you know potentially millions of
them in parallel or having them think
100 times as quickly as human
researchers and working day and night
then it's possible that these other
techniques that don't rely on actual
compute should give you know a burst of
progress where maybe you can improve the
efficiency at which you're running your
AI systems by a factory of 100 maybe you
can improve the efficiency of your
training algorithms Again by a factor of
100 so now you're kind of instead of
training the equivalent of GPT five and
so there's been a significant step up in
the intelligence either maybe in
addition you're getting big gains from
the quality of the data and the
scaffolding and the prompting that that
is they're really significantly
increasing AI capabilities probably the
only organizations who will be able to
do that are ones that have already got a
lot of compute and so you can have all
these kind of AIS doing this AIR
research for them advancing all these
techniques but I think the risk here is
that it becomes very hard to to Monitor
and measure the AI progress
um and govern it for organizations that
have kind of gone over this threshold
where the kind of AI feedback loop is
powerful enough to to power very
significant progress by these
non-compute Avenues at that stage I
think we need to make sure that
um our governance system we kind of
extend it Beyond just tracking and
measuring compute to then kind of having
kind of measures for for tracking what
the progress is within within these
organizations
um they have a very powerful AI systems
and and ways to catch whether these
organizations are are very rapidly
improving their AI systems and so that
we can kind of Monitor and govern that
so trying to evaluate whether AI
assistance Within These companies are
already becoming very capable there's a
two-stage process firstly we track
compute and then we will be kind of
measuring
with those companies that are using a
lot of compute are capable of their AIS
and then for those particular companies
we want to be saying is there a feedback
loop which is enabled just within this
company where that company is able to
have very rapid AI progression without
even getting more compute and so we just
need to be kind of monitoring those top
AI companies in this way yeah I think
this there's some excitement about
evaluating these models for Dangerous
capabilities I I think one one question
I always have there is is just if a
model fails some evaluation what do we
do then I think that we want companies
to pre-commit to what they're going to
do if models fail a particular
evaluation ahead of time so that there's
no ambiguity that should ideally be a
process in place which prevents the
company from just saying ah let's just
go ahead anyway even if in advance
they'd have said that this was this was
a cause of concern so you can imagine a
process where an air can be publicly
committed to do a certain test for
Dangerous capabilities they also
publicly commit that if that dangerous
capabilities test is triggered then they
will pause training until a kind of a
broad group of stakeholders has agreed
that they can continue training that
brought Uber stakeholders might just be
the company's board if they have a board
which is empowered to represent social
interest and and it has agreement Beyond
just um profit maximization you can
imagine it being a broader Google
stakeholders still where there are
people in regulatory authorities or
other auditing organizations that the
company is committed to consult get you
know kind of a majority of agreement
from before continuing with its training
realm but then the company could also
commit to having whistleblown practices
in place so that if it's not following
this process any any employee can
anonymously report that and they're
encouraged to do so one possibility you
you mentioned somewhere is is a case in
which some companies has trained a
powerful AI
and because of their information
security or their cyber security isn't
what it should be that model leaks and
can be potentially used by Bad actors
you mentioned right in the beginning the
the possibility of of bioterrorism via a
capable model what are the best
solutions for for keeping these models
safe or for securing the data my
understanding is that companies are not
at the stage where they can say that
their models are being kept safe that
certainly if a state actor wanted to
steal the weights of a cutting a GI
system they would be able to do so very
easily and probably even kind of lesser
you know kind of smaller threats and
that might be able to steal them more
weight without an excessive amount of
effort yeah I think probably AI
companies
should and probably are seeing it as one
of their priorities to improve their
information security because of these
risks there'll be a great Improvement I
think it's in the interest of the
companies themselves it seems like a
like a win-win for me I don't know if
you agree with that people have
sometimes contrasted the desire to kind
of be the responsible actor that
develops a powerful AI system first for
fear of a less responsible app to
developing it instead if you didn't
plowing ahead they're contracted that
would desire to go slowly and cautiously
yourself I think those two motives come
together in this case where even if your
main worry is actually about you know a
kind of a bad Act of developing AI
systems before you you still want to
improve your security everyone the
people who are worried about these
systems being unsafe and the people who
are worried about wanting to kind of get
them get there first ourselves can all
agree that we want and better and for
security Now if a company was really
irresponsible I can imagine it just just
saying yeah I don't care if some bad
actor steals Rai which we still just
want to make money I'm on the US Market
but the AI companies aren't going to do
that yeah so we've we've discussed how
AI might improve via a lot of additional
compute or via no additional compute and
you've talked about how this might have
a transformative economic impact one
question that I have is if you've taken
all things considered view of this you
think that this will turn out well for
Humanity because a lot of economic
growth could be fantastic and has been
fantastic for for living standards in
the past could we be entering uh into a
a great time or or could be potentially
be entering into a a dangerous time
I think it could be really good or it
could be really awful I think the upside
is
could be really high and I wouldn't
personally think about it in terms of
e-commeric growth but I would think
about it in terms of human flourishing
you could have
you know an end to illness an end
equality and enter material needs you
could have the possibility if you wanted
to of kind of going on
you know any Adventures or fulfilling
any dreams you'd always wanted to pursue
you know with new technologies really
really incredible things might be
possible and I think that that could be
a really amazing future I think it's
it's really hard to paint a concrete
version of what that looks like because
you could analogize it to trying to tell
someone 2000 years ago
all the kind of luxuries and good things
in one society that you could point to
this absolutely incredible entertainment
going into a simulated world where
you're on a real Adventure it's such a
difficult thing to do uh to to sketch
out how amazing things might be it
always kind of feels flat when you when
you say it out loud in a sense but but I
I see I see what you're what you're
aiming for here the picture you're
painting is is of a future in which
could either be very good or very bad do
you see a potential for for a kind of
middle scenario in which the world
continues more or less as it has been
for the past hundred years is that is
that also a live option I think it's
possible so you could imagine
hitting a real Wool with air development
and if that happens then then my default
expectation would be that yeah the kind
of things continues they as they have
been for um you know for as long as it
takes us to get around that war and you
know if that if that rule is really very
permanent then we we begin to get into
worries about the rate of technological
progress stagnating as the population
begins to shrink because fertility is
below replacement rate and you you can
get into actually otherwise if you're
you really start to play out this this
world where
um we don't reach
um AGI you could end up kind of stuck at
current levels of technology for for a
long time potentially
okay let's let's end on a lighter note
and talk about Ai and board games
yeah I've been thinking about what what
does it mean when an AI becomes
superhuman at chess for example has
happened in I think 97 or go which
happened in 2016. I mean in the past you
would you would have people talking
about how chess is the height of of
human intellectual ability but it seems
it now it just seems like we are humans
are playing a lot of Chess there's
there's humans are interested in other
humans playing chess and you know even
though there are some chess some people
are very into chess who watch AIS play
against other AIS it seems that that
this is a domain in which humans are
still very relevant do you think there's
some lesson there for broader AI
automation of the economy probably I am
also a little bit naively surprised at
how many people are still really excited
about the game I think I had the
attitude of okay well if the AI can do
it better than me and that kind of takes
some of the excitement out of it
that said I I'm a passionate diplomacy
player and people who follow AI closely
may know that some ai's recently gotten
pretty good at diplomacy I think still
to feel less good than the best humans
but I think better than the average
humans maybe at least on a text-based
game and it hasn't made me any less
excited to play that game so I think I
was probably just kind of not not
adequately imagining what what it would
feel like for AI to um to kind of be
matching my performance in chess maybe
an implication could be you know even
once AI is better kind of any any task
that you can imagine in the economy
there's still going to be people who are
willing to pay for humans to do tasks
because that's that's something they
find particularly interesting you know
we're still interested to watch humans
play chess we'll probably still be
interested to see humans and produce art
maybe we'll still want to kind of have
human carers human priests so in terms
of economic role for human humans I
think there's maybe points towards us
not being kind of totally obsoleted
because humans kind of like to watch
other humans do things and that that can
give us some kind of job is it worrying
if AIS are getting good at the board
game diplomacy does this mean that they
might be able to do diplomacy in the
real world or that they might be able to
use deception or you can tell me about
the details of the game but that they
might be able to you know set up some
agreement and then break the agreement
afterwards
it is a game where destruction can get
you a long way I would have thought
before it happened that this would be a
milestone that would make me quite
scared about AI deception manipulation
um because it's a fairly complicated
environment and
um that you know the social dynamics are
potentially quite complicated and it's
an exhausting game to play so it kind of
naved it I thought okay I was able to
display and then it's really very
socially
um competent and persuasive and
manipulative in fact you know when you
see the system particular AI system
that's actually able to you know match
have some amateur human performance on
on diplomacy it's not not nearly as as
scary as you might have imagined it's
it's a kind of it's traded on loads and
loads of different examples of diplomas
in particular and loads of examples of
messages that humans sent in diplomacy
games and it's got a kind of engine
which is custom built for choosing what
diplomacy moves to make that won't
easily generalize I'm outside of that
domain you know it seems like it's
actually reaching that threshold not by
kind of thinking of new ingenious plans
and manipulating humans on an Untold
level but just kind of by really
learning the mechanics of the game and
not making mistakes and being consistent
reliable and so it's actually a lot less
scary than I would have thought and I
think it speaks to the difficulty of
designing in advance uh Benchmark that
measures scary capability that will
actually when it when that Benchmark is
passed will actually make you scared
because often you know you pick a
benchmark which seems scary but then the
AI system that matches that Benchmark
just doesn't doesn't actually end up
being as scary as you thought it might
be maybe in 2015 or so deepmind talked
about a a strategy for for getting to
artificial general intelligence which
involved playing ever more complex sport
games and having these reinforcement
learning agents in these uh in these
kind of Worlds where they're able to
navigate more and more complex and then
real world games that's one strategy to
to artificial general intelligence that
the kind of points towards more Agency
for the AI you could call this the
current Paradigm of large language
models there's also a similar kind of
convergence towards agency in AI at
least that's that's what I'm hearing why
is it that both of these strategies push
towards more agency or more agent-like
behavior and AI I think the main thing
pushing language models towards being
more agent-like is that it's useful to
have an agent because an agent can be
more autonomous and can do more
open-ended tasks and potentially
automate larger chunks of your workflow
and I think that's that's why I expect
people to continue to try and improve on
in the trade things like Auto GPT that
turn language models into agents so I
think probably there is there is there's
a kind of economic Force pointing the
direction of creating agents and just a
general you know we want to use the AIS
to do useful things in the world
therefore we'll kind of try and make
them more more identical autonomous I
think there's probably a different thing
that explains deep Minds approach
approach where they're using
reinforcement learning they were
probably making it bet that that was
just the most promising technological
trajectory to get to that end point of
an agent was by just kind of training
agents the whole way and it's being kind
of quite good news from my perspective
that actually it seems like it makes
more sense to First just train language
models to kind of imitate human text
um and then later compose these kind of
little chat Bots into agent like things
because that I think makes it more
promising that we could actually
understand why these agents are behaving
the ways that they are so um thanks for
spending a lot of time with us it's been
very interesting for me thank you so
much it's been a pleasure